Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die Disabler der Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich.
Ok. So als würde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Müller.
Mein Name ist Huba.
Huba?
Ja.
Herr Huba?
Ja, wirklich.
Könnten Sie Ihren Namen für Ihren Beschwerden nennen?
Müller M-U-L-E-R, Huba H-U-B-E-R.
Ok, Huba.
Herr Huba, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45, Frau Doktor.
45?
Wann sind Sie geboren?
1. März 1980.
Ok. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1.69 Meter.
60?
Ja.
Ok. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege 65.
65? Ok.
Ja.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin heißt Herr Wolfgang.
Herr Wolfgang?
Könnten Sie diesen Namen durchstellen?
W-O-N-F-G-A-N-G.
G-A-N-G, ok. Wolfgang.
Vielen Dank für diese Informationen Herr Huba.
Und was für Sie heute so? Was sind Ihre Beschwerden?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Bauchschmerzen. Seit zwei Wochen habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Aber ich habe gewartet.
Ich hatte zuerst Durchfall.
Dann habe ich etwas Joghurt und Kartoffeln gegessen.
Um mich zu verbessern.
Aber mein Bauchschmerzen ist leider schlimm geworden.
Seit zwei Tagen ist es sehr schlimm.
Ich kann es nicht ertragen. Deswegen besuche ich Sie.
Ok. Haben Sie Schmerzen jetzt?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen, Frau Doktor. Deswegen komme ich.
Ok. Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich fühle mich besonders im Unterbau.
Unterbau?
Aber ich fühle mich im Ganzbau.
Ok. Strahlen Sie diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, ganzbau. Ich strahle ganzbau auf.
Ok. Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1-10?
Jetzt oder am Anfang?
Jetzt. Vielleicht 6 oder 7. Das ist nicht sehr schlimm, aber schlimm.
Ok. Können Sie Ihre Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs heraushalten?
Oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzbett?
Ja. Wie viele Minuten dauert das Gespräch?
Ja, es dauert ca. 15 Minuten.
Ok. 15 Minuten egal. Kann ich warten?
Ok. Herr Hüva, sind diese Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten oder plötzlich?
Ja, für zwei Wochen habe ich sie.
Erst war es nicht schlimm, langsam anzupacken.
Dann in der Laufzeit verschlimmert.
Ok. Denken Sie, dass es eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen gibt?
Ja. Was meinen Sie?
Zum Beispiel einige essen Alkohol oder Bewerbung.
Ja, ich habe alles gewöhnlich gegessen.
Ich bin sehr sportlich, trinke keinen Alkohol, keine Zigarette.
Deswegen denke ich, gibt es keinen Auslöser.
Ok. Oder kann ich fragen, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Verstärken oder verschlimmert? Bewerbung, Kollegen?
Ja, normalerweise treibe ich sehr oft Sport.
Aber ich kann nicht jetzt Sport treiben.
Wenn ich schlafe, fühle ich die Schmerzen nicht.
Ich muss nicht sehr oft laufen oder mit Bewerbung verschlimmert.
Ok. Können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen über die Hände oder die Hände dünn?
Ja, ich denke, dass es dunn ist. Schmerzen ist dunn und im Ganzen.
Fühlen Sie sich voll und aufgebläht? Oder haben Sie Blähungen?
Ein bisschen, aber nicht schlimm.
Ok.
Haben Sie jetzt Durfall?
Ja, normalerweise gehe ich zum Klo, wenn ich Stullgang einmal pro zwei Tage mache.
Aber am Anfang hatte ich dreimal zum Klo gegangen.
Jetzt aber einmal oder zweimal.
Mein Stull ist wassrig und cremig.
Aber Farbveränderung habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Das ist wie Braun. Aber es ist wassrig.
Ist Ihnen ein unangenehmer Geruch mit Ihrem Stull?
Nein, nicht.
Sind die Schmerzen gut für mich?
Wie gut für mich?
Sind die Schmerzen in Ihren Rücken strahlen?
Nein, das ist im Bauch, unter dem Bauch und im Ganzen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, ich fühle mich fieberlich, aber ich habe meine Fieber nicht gemessen.
Ok. Und haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Schütterfrost?
Nein, Frau Doktor, das habe ich nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich abgenommen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe innerhalb von zwei Monaten 5 Kilo abgenommen.
Ok, ich bin sportlich, aber ich esse normalerweise gut.
Aber ich habe ungewöhnlich abgenommen. Weiß ich nicht warum.
Aber Ihr Appetit ist gut?
Ja, ich habe kein Problem mit dem Essen. Ich esse alles, Frau Doktor, besonders.
Ok. Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich kann seit zwei Monaten nicht gut schlafen.
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Durchschlafen. In einer Stunde kann ich schlafen.
Haben Sie Stress?
Ja, ich fühle mich stressig und nervös. Das weiß ich nicht warum.
Vielleicht wegen der Arbeit.
Haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Atemnot? Manchmal fühle ich Atemnot, aber Hüsten habe ich nicht.
Hüsten nicht, aber manchmal haben Sie Atemnot. Warum?
Manchmal fühle ich schlecht zu atmen.
Ok. Ist Ihnen ein Vergroßungsgefühl im Bauch aufgefallen?
Im Bauch?
Ja, im Bauch. Haben Sie ein Vergroßungsgefühl oder Schwellung?
Ich habe keine Schwellung, aber ich fühle mich ein wenig mit Druck.
Ich habe Schmerzen und kann meinen Bauch nicht berühren.
Wenn ich tief berühre, fühle ich Schmerzen. Das ist ein Druckgefühl, oder?
Ich meine eine Vollfärbung, besonders links und rechts.
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ok. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Herzstorfen?
Ja, letztes Mal fühle ich mein Herz in meinem Hals.
Ich höre immer mein Herz klopfen. Ist das normal?
Normalerweise höre ich nicht, aber seit zwei Monaten höre ich mein Herz klopfen.
Das ist nicht normal, denke ich. Das stört mich. Ich fühle mich immer.
Ok. Ich suche diese Probleme auch.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser essen?
Nein, habe ich kein Problem beim Wasser essen.
Ok. Herr Hüba, ist Ihnen eine irgendwelche kürzere Erkrankung bekannt?
Ja, vor zwei Monaten, als ich in meinem Hausarzt war,
hat mein Hausarzt mir gesagt, dass ich Bluthochdruck habe,
aber er hat mir keine Medikamente gegeben. Er hat mir empfohlen, Sport zu treiben und Diät zu machen.
Seit zwei Monaten treibe ich Sport, aber auch Salzarm essen.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie mein Hochdruck ist. Ich habe in Nester seit nicht gemessen.
Ok. Noch etwas?
Ich habe keine anderen Erkrankungen. Ich bin ganz gesund. Ich trinke nicht, ich rauche nicht, ich treibe Sport, ich bin jung.
Aber die Arbeit ist sehr stressig. Ich streite immer mit meinen Kollegen seit drei Monaten.
Ich bin Immobilienmakler und die Arbeit ist stressig. Zu Hause habe ich auch Stress.
Manchmal streite ich mit meiner Frau und sie hat mir gesagt, dass ich ein bisschen aggressiv bin in letzter Zeit. Aber ich weiß nicht warum.
Ok. Ich verstehe. Sie haben Bluthochdruck und eine aggressive Stimmung.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie arbeiten in einer Immobilienmakler.
Ich miete und kaufe Haus. Verstehe Sie?
Ja, ich verstehe. Und sind Sie verheiratet? Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine gesunde Kindheit.
Ok. Sehr gut. Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien?
Ich habe keine Allergien.
Ok. Sehr gut. Sind Sie vollständig geübt?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Das ist wichtig für mich, gesund zu sein.
Ok. Das ist eine Routine-Mesik-Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie mit, Parzali. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Niemals.
Ok. Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie treiben regelmäßig Sport. Was machen Sie?
Ich treibe gerne, ich schwimme gerne. Aber seit zwei Wochen kann ich nicht.
Wegen meiner Bauchschmerzen kann ich nicht.
Ok. Ja, ich verstehe. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Bei der Mutter oder bei der Mutter?
Meine Frau leidet an Brustkrebs und behandelt heutzutage mit Chemotherapie.
Ok. Das tut mir sehr leid.
Aber mein Vater ist ganz gesund und mein Bruder ist auch ganz gesund.
Ok. Mutter? Aber Ihre Mutter oder Ihre Frau?
Meine Mutter leidet an Brustkrebs und behandelt Brustkrebs.
Und behandelt mit Chemotherapie.
Chemotherapie. Ok.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein? Sie haben keine Medikamente?
Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente.
Ok. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, ich wurde nicht operiert.
Ok. Ich habe meine ...
Haben Sie manchmal rote Gesicht?
Ja, meine Frau ist mit rote Gesicht aufgefallen.
Sie hat mir gesagt, dass ich gerötet wurde in Nesterzeit.
Aber ich fühle mich nicht. Ich fühle mich heiß.
Ich habe ein heißes Gefühl. Und ich fühle mich warm und fieberig.
Meine Hände, Füße fühlen mich heiß.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich Fieber habe.
Meine Frau hat mir gesagt, dass ich rote Gesicht habe.
Aber weiß ich nicht.
Herr Fieber, ich habe keine weitere Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen? Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Angst.
Mein Kollege ist wegen Darmkrebs gestorben.
Ich habe auch Bauchschmerzen.
Deswegen habe ich Angst, einen Tumor zu haben.
Was kann ich haben? Was vermuten Sie? Was soll ich machen?
Herr Fieber, bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich denke, das ist keine Kräfte.
Aber das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Um eine Notkedeagnose zu stellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Deshalb gibt es leider noch keine Antwort.
Ich werde die Kontakte untersuchen und einige Laborparameter verlassen.
Dann werden wir mit meinem Obersprache sprechen.
Ich kann Ihnen alles sagen.
Ich möchte Sie bitten, noch ein wenig Geduld zu haben.
Führen Sie bei mir Darmspiegelung, Frau Doktor?
Ja, Darmspiegelung kann möglich sein.
Aber ich möchte eine Sonographie, einen Ultraschall machen.
Ich denke, wir können eine CT oder MRT machen.
Sind Sie schmerzlos?
Nein, alle Schmerzen sind schmerzlos.
Das dauert ca. 20 Minuten.
Ich werde Sie schrittweise informieren.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Der Patient heißt Emile Huber.
Er ist 45 Jahre alt, 1,69 m groß und wiegt 5,60 kg.
Herr Huber steht heute bei uns.
Seit zwei Wochen ist er in der Sonne.
Er hat die Schmerzen und Strahlung.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten.
Er hat sich mit der Zeit verschlimmert.
Der Patient berichtete keine bestimmten Auslöser.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt von 8 bis 10.
Bei 6 bis 10.
Auf einer Schmerzkala.
Die Bewegung verschlechtert die Schmerzen.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Stimmung.
Der Patient fühlt sich stressig, nervös, aggressiv.
Seit zwei Wochen berichtet er über Wasser und Krämer.
Und Fleisch am Gesicht.
Er fühlt sich aus wie Füße.
Er berichtete, dass er ausfüllen und warm ist.
Er hat die Temperatur nicht gemessen.
In der vegetative Anamnese ergeben sich Schmerzstörungen.
Er hat eine Gewichtsuhrabnahme von 5 kg in 2 Monaten.
Gewichtverlust von 4 kg innerhalb von 2 Wochen.
Der Patient hat eine Gewichtsuhrabnahme von 5 kg in 2 Wochen.
Der Patient hat eine Gewichtsuhrabnahme von 5 kg innerhalb von 2 Monaten.
Er hat eine Gewichtsuhrabnahme von 5 kg in 2 Wochen.
Er hat keine Medikamente gegen Arteriella hypertonik.
Bei dem Patienten wurde keine Operation durchgeführt.
Er ist nicht rauh und trinkt keinen Alkohol.
Er hat keine Alkohol und Drogenkonsum.
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol und Drogenkonsum.
Die Familie Anamnese zeigt uns, dass ihr Vater gesund ist.
Ich habe ihn bei der Chemotherapie behandelt.
Er hat keine Medikamente.
Er hat keine bekannten Allergien.
Er ist vollständig geübt.
Er arbeitet als Mobiliamakler.
Er ist verheiratet, dass er Kinder hat.
Er hat einen Anamnest, der sich an den Echsten aufreißt.
Um die Abklärung der Beschwerden sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst werde ich meinen Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob es eine Hautveränderung gibt.
Und ob es eine Herzklopenstörung vorhanden ist.
Und ob es eine Herzklopenstörung gibt.
Und ob es eine Abklärung vorhanden ist.
Und ob es eine Herzklopenstörung vorhanden ist.
Und als operativen Untersuchung würde ich eine ultrasonographische Sonographie durchführen.
Und um die möglichen Abdommepathologien zu bestätigen.
Sie sagen immer, MRT des Abdomens oder MRT des Abdomen, MRT des Beins.
Ich würde eine MRT des Abdomens veranlassen um eine andere Karzinom auszuschließen.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall PET-City durchführen?
Ja, ich würde eine PET-City durchführen um die Metastasen zu beherbergen.
Und eine Eko-Kardiographie ist sinnvoll um eine kardiologische Komplikation zu alscheren.
In diesem Fall ist die Apparatusdiagnostik sehr wichtig.
Und?
Und PET-City.
KG.
Und?
Gansendarm von innen untersuchen?
Synthographie, meinen Sie?
Nein?
Von innen.
Ultraschall?
Eine Biopsie? Nein?
Von innen untersuchen.
Von innen.
Innen, wie kann ich das sagen?
Gansendarm von innen untersuchen.
Ah, Koloskopie. Ja, Sie meinen.
Ja, ok.
Müssen wir eine Koloskopie durchführen?
Ja.
Ok.
Und können Sie uns eine Koloskopie aufklären?
Koloskopie ist eine Darm-Spiegelung.
Ja.
Koloskopie ist eine Darm-Spiegelung und...
Wir können mit Hilfe dieser Untersuchung Gansendarm von innen untersuchen.
Ja, ok.
Mit Hilfe der Koloskopie können wir Gansendarm beurteilen.
Gansendarm von innen?
Ja, Gansendarm beurteilen.
Für diese Untersuchung müssen die Patienten mindestens acht Stunden nach dem Keren.
Die Tätigkeitsbitte empfiehlt uns, der Patient soll vor der Untersuchung acht Stunden nüchtern sein.
Soll. Muss.
Soll, nicht muss. Ok. Soll.
Aber muss soll.
Der Patient soll vor der Untersuchung acht Stunden, sechs Stunden nach dem Keren sein.
Nach dem Trinken.
Vor der Untersuchung am Morgen zweitmal ein Liter Wasser trinken.
Der Patient darf essen nicht, aber Wasser trinken erlaubt.
Ok.
Das ist kompliziert, aber nicht einfach.
Diese Unterrichtung macht den Patienten.
Ja, ich möchte fragen, der Patient muss...
Der Patient kann heute erst am Morgen nur einen leichten Frühstück machen.
Der Patient trinkt abends ein Liter Wasser.
Am Morgen trinkt er ein Liter Wasser.
Vor dem Versuch wird er vier Stunden vor dem Keren ausgemacht.
Der Patient muss sechs Stunden vor dem Keren auf der Endoskopie aufhören, oder etwas trinken.
Aber das ist etwas anders als bei Koloskopien.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen, aber der Patient kann einen Tag vorher frühessen.
Dann kann er nichts essen, aber er trinkt viel Wasser.
Er nutzt ein bisschen Nudeln, um die Koloneinheit zu verhindern.
Ok. Und der Patient kann diese Untersuchung...
Ein bisschen unangenehm sein, schmerzfrei.
Nein, diese Untersuchung ist nicht schmerzfrei.
Deshalb kann der Patient ein paar Beruhigungsmittel oder Ganzenarkos.
Ja, unter Narkos.
Diese Untersuchung durchführt unter Narkos oder...
Wir sagen einfach, wir geben dem Patienten leichte Schlafmittel.
Leichte Schlafmittel, ja.
Leichte Schlafmittel.
Ok. Nach der Untersuchung empfehle ich nicht alleine bleiben.
Nach der Untersuchung darf der Patient keine wichtigen Sachen machen.
Habt ihr diese Noten, was ihr habt?
Ich habe diese Aufklärung normalerweise in die Gruppe geschickt.
Aufklärung ist ein anderes Dossier.
Das muss in unserer WhatsApp-Gruppe sein.
Es gibt 8 wichtige Fragen.
Wenn ihr diese Fragen beantwortet, ist das Ende.
Was ist das? Wie ist das? Was ist das für ein Problem?
Ich habe etwas verstanden.
Es gibt 8 wichtige Fragen.
Das ist die Oberar-Summe.
Wenn ihr die Summe-Stratege ist, könnt ihr die ersten 2 Sätze erklären.
Ok.
Ich habe etwas verstanden, aber es gibt noch nicht die Sätze.
Die Kuloskopie hat eine schwierige Darstellung.
Wenn ihr die erste Sätze der Vorbereitung verbreitet,
ist die andere Sätze die gleiche.
Aber die Vorbereitung ist etwas anders als die anderen.
Wir können ein leichtes Frühstück machen.
Der Patient darf Wasser trinken.
Am Abend vor dem Unter- suchungstag soll der Patient
auf Vermitteln und 1 Liter Wasser trinken.
Am Morgen soll der Patient auf Vermitteln
und 1 Liter Wasser trinken.
Ok.
Ich kann euch meine Anleitungen schicken.
Ich habe kein Dose für die Gruppe, da ich neu in die Gruppe bin.
Ich schicken euch die Anleitungen.
Wenn du die ersten Sätze beobachtest,
wie ich es gesagt habe,
die ersten Sätze,
die Grundsatz ist wichtig.
Was wir sagen müssen,
was wir sagen müssen,
wenn du das in deinem Kopf hast, ist es besser.
Das ist die erste Sätze.
Ich habe auch schon etwas gemacht.
Wenn du das aktiv machst,
ist es besser.
Ja.
Ich schaue mal.